[Applause]
[Music]
hey you're back
and that's a good thing what I need you
to do is like follow and subscribe head
ILP and then hit the little bell icon of
this so you can be notified when new
compact talk comes up or when new flash
points come out or when new ILP
information runs that way you can be
notified but in order to get all the
great stuff that we have for you guys
you must hit the like button and you
must subscribe see you soon Macy's
Boxing Gym
you go all the main street fighters come
from 100% as you can see there's a lot
of bags full size ring for your limping
training a lot of champions came in and
out of this place
come here and train young and old every
bag imaginable speed bag heavy bag full
body bag full size ring I'm back toe
with the King now I told you what I told
you about turns Crawford what does that
dude do you see the way that bud moves
and that's his nickname his nickname is
but James Crawford Benavidez didn't
understand exactly how he moved in the
ring he's a different kind of fighter
he's a savant
you have generational fighters and he's
a generational fighter he's a fighter
that you can put in any era and he can
survive in those errors you can put him
in the 40s you could put him in the 50s
60s and 70s any era and he will actually
survive and thrive in those errors
because he is that unique a mixture of
fighter he has inside of him that hunger
to push forward he has the ability to
move and think and he punches in spaces
when I tell you that someone is punching
in spaces that means in between spaces
when somebody is attacking you instead
of automatically going into defense he
goes to an assault pattern all right now
his assault pattern is either the jab up
and he steps him at the right hand or he
throws a hybrid hook uppercut while the
person is engaging him but he's doing
all this on a fly it's like a
supercomputer it breaks down the
information that is given to it it
processes it and it spits it back out in
a way that it's able to decipher the
patterns of the individuals because we
have tells as humans
you know you can tell like if somebody's
gonna throw a jab because maybe they
move their shoulder or maybe they move
their head left and right before they
take a step in and throw a hook to the
body you have to understand the tails
and stuff like that that's what means
Floyd Mayweather so superior to other
fighters is because his fighting style
is reactionary to what the individual is
doing to him and after he processes that
information then he understands how to
break it down that's a generational
fighter that fighter can survive
anywhere and thrive in any situation
that is Terence Crawford the reason why
Terence Crawford is so good if you watch
the fight with him and Benavides what he
did was he used movement to disable a
Benavidez Benavidez couldn't get off on
a job I told you Terence was a surprise
you with his jab being that he was at a
shorter distance with his reach he was
able to step inside establish the jab
then he was able to work the body
Benavidez will cover up so what you
noticed as the fight started to go on
Benavides was game Jose was moving Jose
had good spots but you're gonna have
good spots because bud is going to give
you those spots but it's not gonna back
down so when you're engaging butBut is
going to engage you at the same time so
that's your opportunity but see he
analyzed the rub at your opportunity are
you built for that see a lot of fighters
think they're able to do that but when
your instincts tell you to defend when
you're being attacked
can you just say no I'm gonna go forward
and I'm going to conquer this situation
I'm going to land this counter punch I'm
going to step in I'm going to total hook
to the body while I parry the right
cross that was coming over you know
these little things that you have to
understand that happens in that ring and
once you see that things play out in
front of you then you can understand you
see I didn't think Jose better Vitas was
exactly ready for this fight I thought
that maybe he was three fights away from
actually taking this fight but he took
this fight because he
here there Oh in this title and he felt
that all the fighters that he did fight
he didn't see anything fancy from but
you're not gonna see super flash from
from tennis Crawford you're not gonna
see something like unbelievable punching
power unbelievable speed what you're
going to see is a solid fundamentally
strong fearless individual that is
superior intellect while he's inside
that squared circle so what he uses is
he uses the ropes to his advantage he
uses the referee to his advantage he
uses the difference from pillar to post
to his advantage he uses your knowledge
against you so when you feel that you
have the advantage with your footwork
what he does is he steps on the outside
and remember I told you he's able to go
from southpaw
to Orthodox and it's snap all right so
being that he has that in his arsenal
when you put your right foot out to
swing out when your Orthodox he's going
to step in the middle of you to block
you that's how you stop people from
escaping his escape hatch when you're
fighting right so in order to step away
from somebody after you throw the jab
and you shoot the right hand you can
slide out you can slide in or you can
step laterally over to stop that you
track them when you track them you can
step your left foot into the middle of
his gap of his feet and you can trap him
that way you shoot the right hand into
the belly to the breastplate or to the
face you understand and then you can
follow that with a hook to the body
that's exactly what he did to Benavidez
Benavidez winters blocking defense to
defense and he proceeded to touch his
forearms and then he attacks the body so
what you have to understand here in this
Terence Crawford will always attack the
body all right
that's part of his arsenal
he understands when you break down a
component of a fighter he takes that
away
Benavides was reduced to mean muggin
making faces saying stuff like oh that
didn't hurt it's not about to hurt you
just setting you up for what will hurt
you because the punch you don't sees the
punch that actually hurts you the punch
he didn't see the hybrid uppercut that
he got caught with and the 12th round
see anybody else would have coasted on
that wind alright I had bud winning the
fight by at least five III I didn't
really give Benavidez too many rounds he
probably had two or three rounds on my
scorecard the rest of it was a whitewash
of bud
but it was an entertaining fight okay
not saying that it wasn't entertaining
but he didn't have those answers that
you need for but what you have to do is
start backing but up you have to start
making bud think if you don't do that
if you don't stop his forward momentum
he's just gonna tee off on you he's just
gonna show you his whole arsenal so
again it came in the 12th round I
thought it would come in the 9th and the
10th round because I thought betting
videos will actually engage more because
I know bud punches in between the gaps
and I thought bud will catch him in
between the gaps of the fight I thought
it would be a long grueling fight and
bud will catch him in between the gaps
and actually knock him out the way that
he did do it many meters credit to him
he extended his duration in the fight
two more rounds but inevitably he was
going to be knocked out um if you engage
bud that's a high possibility because
he's going to hit you with shots that
you don't see it's combat talk with the
king
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]